foreign
so anything new today something I should
know there are summaries of the work
that I that I look at so I try to
remember it try to understand it and uh
eventually I played in the games
okay so let's say Bishop C4 after you
move to yeah but what's your idea I mean
so Kim j3
Knight D4
wait wait wait
Community registry
yeah King G4 well first of all he has a
brilliant memory actually I mean it's
literally unbelievable in my opinion
like it's quite often that let's say
like you work on something for like few
days then you show him once then three
days later we have a conversation and I
don't remember what the move is but he
does and it's like yeah I mean it's
obviously a very decent start for uh for
a chess player to to have such a memory